نستكمل تغطيتنا مشاهدينا للصراع الجاري في
السودان والذي اتم اسبوعه الثاني فميدانيا
تجددت الاشتباكات بين الجيش بقياده
البرهان وقوات الدعم السريع بقياده
الجنرال في عده نقاط سيما محيط القصر
الجمهوري بالخرطوم اتهامات متبادله بين
الطرفين بخرق الهدنه الخامسه على وقع
اشتباكات متقطعه داخل العاصمه وخارجها
الجيش واصل طلعاته الجويه بالمروحيات
والطائرات الحربيه على مواقع الدعم السريع
فيما ردت قواته الاخيره بمضادات الطيران
وفي الوقت الذي تتسابق فيه دول العالم
لاجلاء الرعايه اعلنت انقره تعرض طائره
اجلاء تركيه لاطلاق نار بمطار وادي سيدنا
في الخرطوم ولا اصابات الجيش السوداني
اتهم قوات الدعم السريع باستهداف الطائره
التركيه
والاخيره نفت
[موسيقى]
اذا وصل عدد الضحايا في معارك الجنينه
عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور الى 74 قتيلا على
الاقل خلال يومين وفق نقابه اطباء السودان
النقابه اوضحت الرقم في بيان لها ليومي
الرابع والعشرين والخامس والعشرين من
ابريل ولم يتم حصر العدد بعد لوفيات يومي
الاربعاء والخميس في خضم استمرار المعارك
العنيفه في الجنينه
وفي عموم السودان قالت اللجنه التمهيديه
لنقابه اطباء السودان ان عدد المدنيين
الذين قتلوا منذ بدء الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع ارتفع الى
387 وسبعه وثمانين قتيلا وذكرت اللجنه في
بيان ان الاشتباكات اسفرت عن اصابه
1928 مدنيا حتى الان البيان اشار الى سقوط
عشره من القتل المدنيين امس الخميس بينما
اصيب 80 اخرون بينهم حالات غير مستقره
الجيش السوداني كان قد اعلن هدنه جديده
استجابه لمساعي سعوديه امريكيه وعرب الجيش
السوداني عن امله في التزام من وصفهم
بالمتمردين في اشاره لقوه الدعم السريع
بمتطلبات السريان الهدنه اوضح الجيش
السوداني ان تمديد الهدنه تم استجابه
لمساع سعوديه امريكيه لتهيئه الظروف
لاجلاء المقيمين من مختلف الجنسيات
بدورهم رحب اعضاء الاليه الثلاثيه التي
تضم الاتحاد الافريقي والهيئه الحكوميه
الدوليه والامم المتحده بالاضافه الى
السعوديه والامارات وبريطانيا وامريكا
رحبوا باعلان الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع تمديد وقف اطلاق النار الحالي لمده
72 ساعه اضافيه ودعوا الى تنفيذه بالكامل
كما رحبت الاطراف باستعداد طرفي النزاع في
السودان للدخول في حوار من اجل تحقيق وقف
دائم للاعمال العدائيه وضمان وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه دون عوائق
اصدرت قياده الدعم السريع السوداني بيانا
تضمن شكرا وتقديرا للاليه الثلاثيه
واللجنه الرباعيه وشكرت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والولايات المتحده على جهودهم
المستمره في اجلاء المواطنين والمقيمين
منذ اندلاع الازمه في السودان واعلن بيان
الدعم السريع التزامها بمقترح ثلاثيه
والرباعيه بتمديد الهدنه الانسانيه لمده
72 ساعه بدءا من الثانيه عشره من مساء
الخميس السابع والعشرين من ابريل الجاري
ويلتحق بنا من مدينه بورتسودان مراسل
العربيه نزال البقدونس مرحبا بك معي في
هذه الساعه اجلاء الرعايه من بورتسودان لا
يزال متواصلا حتى هذه الساعه كيف هي
الصوره ان كان من معلومات او ارقام جديده
نزار
نعم الارقام في ازدياد والاعداد في ازدياد
والكثافه تتعاظم هنا في مدينه بورسودان
الباصات السفريه تاتي تباعا الى هذه
المدينه تقل عشرات الاسر ومئات الاسر التي
تصل من العاصمه الخرطوم
بوسط السودان تصل من مدينه عطبره بشمال
السودان تصل ايضا من مدينه مدينه واد مدني
بوسط السودان كل هذه المدن الان ياتي منها
المغادرون ياتي منها الذين يرغبون في
مغادره السودان في عمليه الاجلاء الكبرى
عبر هذا المنفذ البحري وعبر المنفذ الجوي
ايضا في مدينه بورسودان عشرات كما ذكرنا
بل مئات من الاسر ما زالت تاتي الى هذه
المدينه اعداد كبيره منهم الان في طريقهم
ايضا الى مدينه
بورسودان سنحاول ان نقترب اكثر لنعكس لكم
عبر هذه الصوره الحيه التفاصيل استقبال
الذين يرغبون في مغادره السودان وما يقدم
من خدمات والبعد الشعبي والبعد الاجتماعي
الذي
يتعاطى ايجابا مع هذه الاعداد التي تشهدها
مدينه بورسودان يمكن لاول مره هذه النسب
من العائلات ومن الاسر التي تصل الى مدينه
بورسودان هذه هي مجموعه من شباب مدينه
الان تعمل على تقديم مياه الشرب النقيه
لمئات الاسر الموجوده داخل مركز حصر
وتنسيق
وتوفيق اوضاع من يريدون مغادره السودان
خلال الساعات المقبله الشرطه السودانيه
ايضا تعمل على تامين وعلى حمايه هذا
المركز وتنسيق الجهود بين الشرطه وبين
اداره الجوازات ايضا كما نتابع قيادات
الجيش السوداني ايضا تعمل بتناغم مع مختلف
القيادات ومع مختلف الوحدات الفنيه
والاداريه في هذا المركز سنقترب اكثر
بصوره داخل هذا المركز
لتن وتوفيق اوضاع مئات الاسر النسبه
الاكبر هنا في هذا المركزي للسوريين الذين
وصلوا بعدد يقدر باربعه الاف سوري يطلبون
مغادره السودان ويطلبون
الاجلاء خلال الساعات المقبله تحدثنا الى
كثير منهم العقبه الرئيس الان تتمثل في
عدم تحديد ميقات الزماني للمغادره تم
تسليم الجوازات من قبلهم للجهات المعنيه
وهم الان ينتظرون دورهم في مغادره
بورسودان الى عدد من الوجهات منها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه منها سوريا لكن اوضاعهم
تظل كما تتابعون الان عشرات الاسر تحت هذه
الخيم استظلوا بالشمس خلال الساعات
الماضيه عديده الجهات الخيريه والحكومه
هنا ايضا تعمل على توفير الامكانيات
المتاحه بحسب ما تمتلك من امكانيات على ان
تمضي الامور كما هي ايضا عدد من المواطنين
ايضا يقدمون الدعم والسند ويوجهون ايضا
السوريين بان هنالك مناطق ايواء وهكذا
ينادون عليهم كما استمع الان الى احد
مواطنين مدينه بورسودان هو الان يوجه عدد
يوجه عدد من السوريين واليمنيين بان هنالك
عدد من مناطق الايواء لو اعطيتنا فكره
عامه يحدث وما هو الدعم الذي يقدم من
قبلكم انتم كلجنه بسم الله الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
نحن الان مسؤولين كلجنا من الترحيل حسن
الان عندنا حفلاتنا جاهزه عندنا المناطق
جاهزه باذن الله تعالى بالنادي بالناس على
اساس انه السوريين والناس
اللي لسه جرعاتهم مكتمله عندنا داخليتين
مجهزه من كل شيء حتى اذا الجهاد في الجهات
خيريه انه نقوم في مواقع هذا الدعم الشعبي
ام رسمي من هيئه الم البحريه وحتى اللون
الحفلات الموجوده من هيئه الامم البحريه
نحن بنقوم بالتنسيق مع اللجنه العليا هنا
بنقومنا حول الناس لعب مناطق بتاعتي امنه
فيها حمامات فيها بس بنفرز الرجال من
النساء لكن التحدي كبير بالنسبه لكم
التحدي كبير جدا بالنسبه لنا ولكن الناس
يفهموا وينظموه يعني يعني حسن
بنقول للناس انه يعني
مثلا الزول كبير مع العفش اما الناس
الثانيين انه النساء عملنا لهم موقع محدد
الرجال عملناها لموقع محدد نحن كهيئه مهند
البحريه ان شاء الله جاهزين وان ارحل
الناس لمناطق الايواء ونرجعهم من مناطق
اللواء ان شاء الله ليعملوا اجراءاتهم
وبرضو هنرحلنا ان شاء الله للبواخر ويعود
الى بلد هل عملتم على حصر النسب للاسر
للشباب للشيوخ والله نحن حتى الان الحصر
صعب حقيقه يعني
قبل يومين مع الاخوان الصينيين وشلناهم من
مناطق الهواء وطوالي الى البواخر الحمد
لله وكان الشغل مشى بطريقه سلسه جدا الشغل
هنا التنظيم على اساس انه الناس يعني
يعرفوا وكتم 200 نحن من مناطق
ان شاء الله نحن جاهزين على كله وجزاكم
الله خير وبارك الله فيكم هذا هو صوت
الجهد الذي يقدم ازاي هذه الازمه
المتواصله وصول المئات الى مدينه بورسودان
وعشرات الحالات الحرجه ايضا لاحظناها
للنساء في حالات متعسره بعض الاطفال بعض
الشيوخ كل هذه المشاهد وكل هذه الصور ان
عكاسات لازمه حدثت قبل 14 يوم وما زالت
تبعاتها وتاثيراتها وتداعياتها مستمره حتى
الان نزار يعني اذا استطعت ان تاخذ يعني
حديث احد يعني هؤلاء الذين ينتظرون في
ميناء بورتسودان الحديث عن الرحله من
الخرطوم الى بورتسودان كيف كانت ايضا
المصاعب التي واجهوها اثناء بقائهم حتى في
الخرطوم اذا استطعت
نعم سنحاول ذلك وسنستمع ايضا الى بعض
الافادات وبعض القصص حول الطريقه التي وصل
بها السوريون ووصل بها الاردنيون ووصل بها
اليمنيون الى هذه المدينه ساحاول ان نقترب
اكثر نحاول نحاول ان نقترب اكثر نحن الان
على الهواء مباشره كيف كانت الرحله من
الخرطوم الى هذه المدينه بورسودان والله
صعبه كثير صعبه شديد وفي ناس معاهم عيال
واولاد مشكله
يعني كتير صعبه يعني في عالم 16 ساعه 17
ساعه من الخرطوم الى مدينه بورسودان نعم
17 ساعه
يعني وعذاب كتير والحمد لله اجينا لهون ما
قصروا معنا ونحن عم نقترح على العم في
مدارس هنا اذا بتفتح نقعد فيها بس لبين ما
الله ييسر امورنا عرفت كيف لانه هو
المطلوب هذا المطلوب انه في مدار السنه
قريبه فيها حمامات يعني بتقوي الناس بتسهل
الامور شوي بس اعداد كبيره اعداد كتير اسا
انا في ناس معاهم عيال في ناس معاهم نسوان
مشاكل يعني مشكله وما حدا عم يسالها من
الاخير يعني انا حابب احكي كلمه بس ما
تقطعوها
بتمنى منكم ما تقطعوا نحن على الهواء الان
انتم على الهوى يعني احنا حاسين حالنا
ترج غنم هيك يعني دايرين حدا يجي بس
يسيرنا بالعصا يعني انت الان تطالب
بالسفاره يعني حدا يتكلم فينا بس في ناس
معه في ناس معهم نسوان يعني اي واحد بيعني
هالكلام اذا بحب يكون اخته ومرته شرفه
وهيك متشرط بالشوارع جماعه ما قصروا معنا
والله شالونا وساعدونا كتير بس في حد يعني
المفروض بس يعني والله لو طرش غنمه هيك
اذا هي الرساله واضحه نعم هي الرساله
واضحه للسوريين لليمنيين لعديد الجاليات
التي تطالب الان بتوفيق اوضاعها باسرع مما
يكون نسبه للوضع الحرج الذي تعيشه الاسر
في هذه المنطقه هم الان يستعدون لمغادره
شرق السودان الى عدد من الدول في المنطقه
والاقليم اشكرك جزيل الشكر على هذه الصوره
رحبت القوى المدنيه الموقعه على الاتفاق
الايطالي في السودان بالمبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه لتمديد الهدنه لمده 72 ساعه
وشددت على ضروره الالتزام بها من اجل
الوصول لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار واضافت
انها تتابع عن كتب خطوات تنفيذ المبادره
الامريكيه السعوديه الراميه لوقف
المواجهات في السودان وتشد على ايدي قياده
القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع التي تعاطت
بايجابيه مع هذه المبادره
ضمن تفاعلها مع الوضع الانساني القائم في
السودان شكلت الحكومه الاثيوبيه لجنه
وطنيه لتسهيل عبور النازحين من الصراع
الدائري في السودان ودعت الحكومه
الاثيوبيه اطراف الصراع السوداني واقفل
القتال وانهاء معاناه المدنيين واكدت
دعمها للحلول السودانيه من دون تدخل اطراف
خارجيه
نتابع بقلق بالغ تطورات ما يجري في
السودان وقد قمنا بتشكيل لجنه وطنيه
تتراسها الخارجيه الاثيوبيه بالتعاون مع
جهات رسميه اخرى وقد قمنا بارسال فريق الى
الحدود مع السودان للقيام بتسهيل عبور
النازحين من الحرب الدائره هناك ونامل ان
يحل السلام في السودان في اقرب وقت ممكن
واضمن ردود الفعل الاقليميه للصراع دائري
في السودان بين قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع اكدت الخارجيه الاثيوبيه
عبرت عن قلقها لما يدور في السودان وان
المفاوضات الثلاثيه لسد النهضه لن تستانف
ما لم يحل السلام في السودان
في السودان له تاثيرات سلبيه على
المفاوضات الثلاثيه في قضيه سد النهضه ولا
يمكن استئناف المفاوضات ما لم يحل السلام
في السودان ويكون هناك تركيز تام من
الجانب السوداني هذا الوضع يجعلنا ننتظر
حلول السلام في السودان
اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي باحمد عن
اجراء مباحثات هاتفيه مع قائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو بشان ضروره
تسويه الخلافات بين الجانبين اكد ابي احمد
عبر حسابه على تويتر انه ناقش مع البرهان
ودجل ايضا ضروره تحقيق الاستقرار في
السودان وتسويه الخلافات بعد الاشتباكات
التي اندلعت بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
هذا وقالت الخارجيه الاثيوبيه بانها تقدر
الظروف التي يمر بها السودان وتبذل قصارى
جهدها لدعم جهود وقف الصراع كما اشارت
الخارجيه الاثيوبيه الى تشكيل لجنه وطنيه
اثيوبيه لتسهيل عبور النازحين من الصراع
في السودان واضافت بانها تامل في ان يتوصل
اطراف الصراع في السودان لاتفاق دون تدخل
اطراف خارجيه
قال وزير خارجيه الامريكيه ان الولايات
المتحده ترحب باعلان طرفي الصراع في
السودان تمديد الهدنه الى 72 ساعه جديده
اضاف بلينكن ان بلاده تحط الاطراف
السودانيه على الالتزام بوقف القتال وضمان
وصول المساعدات دون عراقيل
نعمل بشكل نشط لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار
كانت لدينا هدنه لمده 72 ساعه ورغم انها
لم تكن فتره مثاليه لكنها قللت من اعمال
العنف وخلق الظروف افضل للسودانيين كما
ساعدت في تسهيل مرور المساعدات الانسانيه
ونريد التاكد ان كان ممكن ان تمديد الهدنه
فنحن منخرطون بشكل كبير
وينضم الي هنا في الاستوديو الصحفي فتح
الرحمن يوسف سيد فتح الرحمن حياك الله معي
في هذه التغطيه على شاشه العربيه اريد
بدايه ان اسال عن هذه الخطوات والمساعي
الاثيوبيه يعني هي اليوم اعلنت عن تشكيل
لجنه وطنيه لتسهيل عبور النازحين ابي احمد
قال انه تواصل مع البرهان تواصل كذلك ايضا
مع
الدوله الاثيوبيهن كيف يمكن الحديث عنه ما
الذي يمكن ان يصير عنه ايضا
طيب شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه وتحيه لك
وللمشاهدين الاعزاء يعني انا اعتقد
اثيوبيا
يعني يقع عليها ايضا تقوم بدوره كبير في
تحريك المياه الراكده الان في العمليه
السياسيه او عمليه التفاوض بين الاطراف
المتنازعه في السودان بحكم انه اثيوبيا هي
جار للسودان وبينهما حدود
وايضا هناك يعني مصالح مشتركه
ولا يتجزا بالتاكيد الامن والاستقرار في
المنطقه فكله يكمل بعضه وبالتالي
تشهد على يعني فتره قريبه كانت تشهد حرب
بين التاجراي والحكومه الاثيوبيه وكان في
الغالب العام يشعر به انه هناك اشكاليه في
انه كيف يعني
يضمن الجانب السوداني في في مساله
الاستقبال اللاجئين في عهد الحرب كيف يمكن
ان يساهموا في الاستقرار في في اثيوبيا
كيف يمكن ان او بنفسهم على التسريحه
المعارضه عن استغلال المعارضه في المعارك
ضد اثيوبيا هذه الاشياء وهذا الارتباط
يعني هناك حاله من القلق الاقليمي للدول
المجاوره
تحاول يعني هل من المفترض الان ان تحاول
تثبيت الهدنه التي توصف بانها هشه واقترقت
كم مره ام ان تحاول ان تجمع اطراف الصراع
على طاوله التفاوض حتى تبحث عن حل سياسي
لان الهدنه اخترقت كم مره ويبدو انها يعني
لن تحقق اختراقا خلال الايام القادمه هذا
حسب ما يتابعه بعض هو للاسف الشديد بحكم
انه الصراع يعني صراع اشتباك مباشر
وهذا الاشتباك المباشر الدماء التي سالت
الرصاص القصيره الذي سقط على بيوت وعلى
مدنيين مع العسكريين ومتى كثير منهم اكثر
من 500 وجرح اكثر من 5000 في هذه وما زالت
الاعداد في ازدياد في هذا الجو الذي يصعب
الكنترول او السيطره عليه مساله الهدنه
تكون هي مطلب انساني في المقام الاول
وممكن تكون تهدئه
للنفوس في حدود محدوده جدا ولكنها لن تكن
هي غير مسكن لن تكون هي المخرج المنفذ
لايجاد حلول
وبالتالي الجلوس الى بعض
وحل الازمه في غضور ايام هذا اعتقد للاسف
يعني هو من الصعوبه بمكانه يحدث كل هذه
الهدن التي تحدث هي هي تعتبر هي هي جهد
المقل بالنسبه للمجتمع الدولي والمجتمع
الاقليمي وحتى بالنسبه لدول الجيران
اذا كان تكلمنا عن الجنوب السودان اثيوبي
عن هذه تكون هي جهود مقله ولكن هو جهد
يعني لا يستطيعون ان ينفذون انا اعتقد في
ظل هذا الظرف لانه هناك تحرك من الطرفين
نحو الاشتباك نحن نعرف ان هناك اشتباك
مستمر يعني هناك
مستمر نسبه لان القوات الدعم السريع تتخذ
من بعض الاحياء ملاتي لها
وفي كثير من الاحيان ينقطع التواصل بينها
وبالتالي هذه تسبب
الامس الحديث عنها مساله التواصل بين
الافراد وعناصر الدعم السريع مع القياده
هل هناك معلومات مؤكده بان هناك انقطاع او
شبه انقطاع في التواصل اذا كان صحيحا ما
الذي يدلل على ذلك اصلا الذي يدل على ذلك
الخروقات يعني عندما يحدث تنطلق فتنه
والقاعده في طرفين يتحدثون عن
التزام للهدنه وفجاه نسمع
الاشتباك حصل هنا وهناك هذا واحد من
المؤشرات وقد يكون يعني عن قصد ولكن نحن
نتحدث عن يعني توقعات نتوقع ان يكون هناك
عدم تواصل واصلا اصلا للاسف الجديد شبكه
الاتصالات هي الان متعزمه وفي حاله انقطاع
مصلحه الخدمات الاخرى خدمات الكهرباء التي
خرجت من الخدمه وخدمات المياه
والمستشفيات وكذا جزء من هذه الخدمات لكن
لماذا دائما نقول ان قوات الدعم السريع
مثلا فقدت الاتصال بقياداتها وخرق الهدنه
اصلا
يعني هو من الطرفين كل طرف يتهم الاخر
فبالتالي الا يمكن ايضا حتى ان الجيش قد
يكون فقد التواصل مع قياداته على الارض
هناك فرق كبيره صحيح ممكن يكون هناك
نوع من انواع الثقه بين الطرفين وبالتالي
الهدنه لا تستطيع ان تحجم
الاشتباك يعني لانه كله طرف يبقى يكسب من
الوقت ويحقق مكاسب على الارض وبالتالي
تصير الخدمه في حاله عدم ثقه وعدم وعدم
الاستقرار يعني تحصل هذه الخرقان كل من
الاطراف يبغى ان يحقق يعني ولكن اذا
تحدثنا عن الجيش الجيش يختلف يا استاذنا
عن
الجيش مؤسسه مؤسسه اصيله
يعني يعني ترتكز على بنيه تحتيها
مهيئه تماما لاداره المعارك يعني هي تعاد
تدير معركتها من 80 سنه يعني وبالتالي من
الصعوبه ومعارك شرسه يعني معركه الخرطوم
الان هي معركه استثنائيه ومعركه يعني غير
قناه غير متوقعه كونه تشهد الخرطوم لاول
مره معركه بهذا الشكل الذي ان تتسبب في
افراغ الخرطوم
المجتمع المدني
والدبلوماسيين الخرطوم لافراغها من المكون
المدني للاسف الشديد اذا نحن نتحدث من قبل
يومين تقديرات بان هناك ستين في المئه من
النازحين وما زالت هناك نعم وماذا
تقريبا الان هي ثلاثه مدن
الخرطوم وخرطوم بحري والخرطوم
البحريها لانه محاول ايضا هي تعتبر
امتدادات لها
يعني مثلا التي كان فيها حاور حاولت قوات
دعم
مواقع اخرى يعني بالنسبه للمواقع الرئيسيه
المفصليه الهامه في العاصمه الخرطوم نتحدث
عن مطار العاصمه نتحدث عن القصر الجمهوري
والقياده العملي القوات المسلحه السودانيه
ما هو وضعها اليوم بعد اسبوعين من
الاشتباكات من يملك السيطره عليها والله
شوف انا للاسف الشديد والكلام ده انا اقدر
اقوله قوه الدعم السريع كانت اصلا هي
مبيتا هي واضحه انها هي تستوي على هذه
المقرات
الرمزيه الان
نحن يعني شفنا انقلابات عسكريه سبقت هذه
الانقلابات دائما يكون هناك
الانقلاب ينجح عندما يتم
يتم الاستيلاء على هذه المباراه الشمسيه
دائما وابدا اذا ما تم الاشتراع هيئه
الاذاعه والتلفزيون واذاعه البيان وتم
الاستيلاء على المطار وتم الاستيلاء على
القصر الجمهوري بالتاكيد
الانقلاب سيفشل وبالتالي العراق هنا سيظل
الوقت وان كنت افهم على ان الجيش هو
المتقدم غازي ولكن الجيش يتعامل بشكل
تقني يعني لانه هو مسيطر انا لا اقول
مسيطره تماما ولكن استطيع ان يسيطر فقط
اذا احب ان يسيطر بالفعل
سنفقد ارواح هذه هي المشكله هذه هي
المشكله ولكن غير ذلك ما في مشكله انا
متاكده عن جاهزيه يعني هل ينتظر الجيش الى
ان تفرغ العاصمه الخرطوم تماما من
المدنيين وبعد ذلك
ولكن اذا اذا تم افراغون بهذا نحو الذي
نحن نراه الان هذا سيساعد في مزيد من
اشتباكات ولذلك نسمع عن غيرك او عن بعض
البلاد الاخرى التي تنظر الى الوضع بشكل
يعني اخر تحس بان الوضع يمكن نحو التعزم
ونحو كما ذكر البيت الابيض والخارجيه وهذا
اكيد يعني
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على وجودك معي هنا في
الاستوديو والصحه في فتح الرحمن يوسف شكرا
جزيلا لك شكرا لك شكرا اذا تابعت كاميرا
العربيه اللحظات الاولى لوصول سفينه جلاله
الملك الجبيل الى قاعده ملك فيصل البحريه
بمدينه جده في السعوديه
بدا عمليات تجهيز السلم لبدء انزال
الرعايه
القادمين من ميناء بورت سودان وعددهم 52
شخص من من 12 جنسيه نتحدث على
الدبلوماسيين وعائلات واطفال وحتى كذلك
كبار سن لانه شاهد القوات العسكريه
متواجده لاستقبال الرعايه هنا في هذا في
رصيف قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بعد رحله
استمرت عشره ساعات كنا على متن هذه
السفينه نرافقها من قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بجده الى ميناء بورد السودان
واستمرت عمليات الاجلاء في ظرف ساعه واحده
فقط عبر الزوارق سريعه قامت بنقل الرعايه
من ميناء بورت سودان الى
ظهر هذه السفينه السفينه جلاله الملك
الجبيل التابعه للقوات البحريه السعوديه
ومن ثم انطلقت مباشره من المياه الاقليميه
السودانيه الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده في رحله استغرقت كذلك عشره ساعات
فيما يتعلق التجهيزات الخاصه بالرعايه هنا
قامت القوات البحريه السعوديه بتجهيز غرف
النوم وثكانات لهؤلاء الرعايه وكذلك توفير
كافه المواد التموينيه والاعاشيه وكذلك تم
الكشف والتاكد من صحته وسلامه كافه
الرعايه من خلال وجود عياده طبيه هي مجهزه
للتعامل مع الحوادث والاصابات وكذلك اجراء
العمليات الخفيفه من خلال الاطباء عسكريين
سعوديين متواجدون في هذه العياده للتعامل
مع اي حاله كذلك تم فتح كافه المواقع
المخصصه للاعاشه لهؤلاء الرعايه حتى
يستطيعوا التزود من الطعام والمشروبات
شابه ذلك طوال مده الرحله كذلك التعامل
بشكل انساني كبير جدا وواضح خلال طوال هذه
الرحله من خلال التعامل مع الرعايه وعند
اقترابنا من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
ودخلنا المياه الاقليميه السعوديه التقينا
بعدد كبير من الرعايه نتحدث على يعني
شرحوا وعبر لنا عن امتنانهم وتقديرهم
الحكومه السعوديه
اجلائهم من ميناء بورتسودان بعد ان كانوا
في الخرطوم وقاموا بالسفر برا الى ميناء
بورسودان في مده او في مسافه 850 كيلو متر
يعني وثقوا هذه اللحظات عند اقترابهم
لقاده ملك فيصل البحريه بجده والثقوا
عبرها هواتفهم هذه اللقطات واختلفت
المشاعر بعد ان كان هنالك مشاعر خوف وعدم
استقرار اختلفت كليا بعد وصولهم الى بر
الامان هنا على ارض على ارض السعوديه
وتحديدا فعلى رصيف قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بجده
سفينه جلاله الملك الجبيل السعودي
تم تدشينها في مارس من عام 2022
ولعبت دورا فاعلا في عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان ونقلت رعايا السعوديين ومن عده
دول اخرى من بورت سودان الى جده هذه
العمليه الثانيه
اول عمليه
في واقع 50 شخص تم اجراهم الى قاعده الملك
فيصل بجده
السفينه من طراز كورفيت افانتي 2200 وهي
اولى السفن التي دخلت الخدمه ضمن مشروع
الثروات وتعد الاحدث من طرازها في العالم
تابعت العربيه لحظات الاولى لوصول سفينه
جلاله الملك مكه الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بمدينه جده في السعوديه وعلى
متنها
1995 شخصا من ثمانيه عشره جنسيه مختلفه
وصلت الان
الى جلاله الملك مكه وهذا تاكيدا على
عمليات استمرار عمليات استمرار الاجلاء
الخاصه بالرعايه من ميناء بورت سودان الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه عبر السفن
البحريه الخاصه بالقوات السعوديه البحريه
نتحدث على متن سفينه جلاله الملك مكلتي
وصلت الان
198 الشخص من نتحدث من ثمانيه عشر
جنسيه جميعهم من المواطنين الاجانب وصلوا
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بعد رحله
استمرت قرابه العشره ساعات من بورتسودان
وتحديدا من ميناء بورد السودان
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه الان بدا
عمليات الانزال من خلال تركيب السلم الخاص
بالرصيف البحري الخاص بقاعه الملك فيصل
البحريه دقائق معدوده وسوف يقومون بعمليات
الانزال بدءا من النساء وكبار السن وذوي
الاحتي الخاصه وبعد ذلك بقيه الركاب
[موسيقى]
دعا وزير الخارجيه البريطاني مواطنه في
السودان الى الذهاب الى المطار في اسرع
وقت ممكن لضمان سلامتهم وقال في حسابه على
تويتر
تمديد وقف اطلاق النار في السودان المملكه
المتحده تدعو الى تنفيذها الكامل من قبل
الجنرالات واضاف احث جميع الرعايه
البريطانيين الراغبين في المغادره على
التوجه الى المطار في اسرع وقت ممكن لضمان
سلامتهم
ينظم الي هنا في الاستديو والسفير
البريطاني لدى السعوديه
مرحبا بك سعاده السفير معي على شاشه
العربيه بدايه اسالك عن المواطنين
المواطنين البريطانيون الذين تم اجلائهم
من السودان كم وصلت الاعداد حتى هذه
اللحظه
بدات العمليه البريطانيه قبل ايام
في مطار في وادي صعيدنا الى الشمال من
الخاتون مطار وادي سيدنا وتم اجراء
المواطنين على على الطائره
العسكريه على السلاح البريطاني
الطائرات مباشره من سيدنا الى القبرص الى
طبعا هناك طرق اخرى بعد المواطنين
البريطانيين
[موسيقى]
الى
السودان
ومن هناك سافروا على المتن سفن او طائرات
سعوديه او غير سعوديه الى جده حتى الان
عضون اكثر من ثلاثه 530 مواطن سافروا
[موسيقى]
انت وقفت ايضا على حالتهم الصحيه النفسيه
الجسديه ايضا
لمواطنينكم الذين تم اجلؤهم الى السعوديه
ما هي حالته وطبعا
كانت الخبره خبره خائفه
كثير منهم كانوا في احوال صعبه في الاثناء
القتال شاهدوا القتال والقصف
والرحله من رحله من
طويل اظنهم
تعبين هم لا يزال يشعروا بالخوف
اقارب في السودان ولكن اظن في جده
يستطيعون ان يستريحوا
يعني اذا
يحتاجوا الى الخدمات الطبيه يستطيعون ان
يرخوا الى
المستشفيات السعوديه
طيب هل اصيب اي من
مواطنينكم في السودان خلال هذه الاشتباكات
في فتره الاسبوعين الماضيه انا لست متاكدا
هذا انا
طيب
هل من المتوقع اجراء مزيد ايضا من مواطنكم
من المملكه المواطنين المملكه المتحده
بريطانيا في السودان
اظن ان العمليه الجويه سوف تستمر لعده
ايام يعتمد على الوضع على الارض لكن وانا
انا من
الكثير من الاجانب سوف يحاولون ان يسافروا
من طرق اخرى مثل
السودان
الطائرات البريطانيه من وادي سيدنا تقل
بريطانيين الى لندن او ايضا عدد من
الجنسيات الاخرى الصديقه والحدث من
الجنسيات الاخرى
هل سيبقون في جدهم سيتم نقلهم الى الى
بريطانيا مباشره
من وادي سيدنا هم من وادي سيدنا الى
الرحلات الى جده
الى جده
ونحن نرتب السفر من جده الى لندانه يعني
هم سيتحركوا مباشره
السعوديه الجويه سعوديه او اي خطوط جويه
اخرى
ما هي رسالتكم التي تودون نقلها الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بعد جهودها في
اجلاء مواطنيكم البريطانيين او حتى ايضا
من مواطنين
نحن نقدر الجهود التي بدلت السعوديه كان
تنسيق مستمر من بدايه الازمه اظن
قد تحدث مع سمو الاميه فيصل اعضاء مراد من
صحيه تنسيق ولكن ان اود ان اشكر السلطان
السعودي والشعب السعودي المساعده التي
قدمت السلطات السعوديه للمواطنين
المواطنين البريطانيين كل المواطنين
الاجانب يعني طبعا السعوديه معروفه للروح
الضيافه والحفاوه ولكن في هذه
الحاله ان
المساعده على مستوى عالي ونحن بانني لكم
شكرا جزيلا لك نتمنى السلام لكل مواطنكم
لكل ايضا حتى اللاجئين الذين يخرجون من
السودان بمختلف اجناسهم وعراقهم وكل
جنسيتهم شكرا جزيلا لك كان معي هنا في
الاستوديو السفير البريطاني لدى السعوديه
حصلت ايضا المشاهدين قناه العربيه على صور
حصريه لعمليات الاجلاء الجوي للرعايه
الاجانب من السودان والتي تجري تحت اشراف
الجيش السوداني حيث تظهر الصور اصطفاف
طائرات عسكريه لاجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
وحتى السودانيين ايضا
[موسيقى]
هذا واظهرت صور تم التقاطها بطائره دون
طيار استمرار عمليات الاجلاء للمواطنين
والدبلوماسيين في الميناء البحري الرئيسي
شرق السودان
[موسيقى]
قال وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان دينج داو في
تصريحات خاصه للعربيه ان بلاده مستمره في
جهودها لاقناع طرفي الصراع بوقف القتال
والتفاوض مضيفا ان جنوب السودان لم تحصل
على موافقه رسميه من البرهان بشان مبادره
ايجاد وان حكومته تجد صعوبه في الوصول الى
قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو هاتفيا
منذ سته ايام
ولدينا من
برهان طبعا من سته يوم حسي الاتصال
يعني طبعا بنعرف الظروف تذهب يمكن القائد
وتغيير في المحال وتمشي للمحال معين
حتى في وقت
انه الناس يكونوا يتصلوا في اي وقت
رسلنا
رسلنا له رسلنا
البرهان
الرئيس الفقير نيابه عن الدول اللي جات
في لقاء خاص مع العربيه اقل متحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي في البيت الابيض جون
كيربي ان جهود بلاده مستمره لتمديد وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان مؤكدا العمل بصوره
حديثه مع طرفي الصراع لاجل ذلك
جهود مستمره من وزاره الخارجيه ويتراسها
السيد انتوني بلينكل لتمديد وقف اطلاق
النار في الايام المقبله ولقد راينا
تخفيضا في اعمال العنف التي طالت كافه
انحاء السودان لكن هناك بعض المناطق التي
لا تزال تشهد عنفا ومع ذلك تراجع العنف
ونعمل بصوره حديثه للتواصل مع الطرفين
لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار
نحن نرحب بمبادره ايجاد او اي مبادره اخرى
من اجل وقف القتال وادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه
شركاءنا السعوديون ساعدونا كثيرا في اجلاء
مواطنين واجلاء اعداد كبيره من الرعايا
الاجانب عبر ميناء بورتسودان ونحن ممتنون
بما تقدمه في هذا الخصوص
من امدرمان تنضم الينا الصحفيه فاطمه
ابراهيم مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه على
شاشه العربيه الاوضاع في ام درمان كيف
تبدو ميدانيا حتى هذه اللحظه
تحيه لكم تحيه لكل المتابعين قناه العربيه
لو تستمع الان الى اصوات الطائرات الان
تحلق في السماء اندرمان متجهه شمالا حيث
توجد عدد من معسكرات الدعم السريع شمال
اندرمان ربما ما زالت يعني عمليات ايضا
التنشيط مستمره هنا في اندرمان كما كان
قبل قليل بعض صلاه الجمعه مباشره شهدت
منطقه السرورات شمال ام درمان تظاهرات
مؤيده للجيش تردد شعار جيش واحد شعب واحد
فبالتالي تزداد يعني
التظاهرات التي تؤيد للجيش من قبل
المواطنين ايضا استيقظت صباح اليوم او
استيقظ صباح اليوم سكان ام درمان تحديدا
لا سي مناطق مختلفه من الخرطوم والخرطوم
بحري باصوات من الرصاص والغذائف ومضادات
الطيران الحربي التي كانت تحلق في السماء
في ظل طبعا تجاهل الهدنه التي
اعلانها خاصه الهدنه الانسانيه يعني التي
تم اعلانها من قبل طرفي النزاع
وكان قد اعلن ايضا الجيش السوداني على
صفحته على فيسبوك موافقته على تمديد هذه
الهدنه التي يعني
المواطن السوداني في امس الحوجه اليها في
هذا الوقت تحديدا ولكن ربما يعني باءت هذه
المحاولات للهدنه بالفشل فما زال
المواطنون ايضا يستمعون لي الاصوات الرصاص
والغذائف والطيران ايضا ما زال يحلق وايضا
ما زالت يعني
الجاليات الاجنبيه
يعني
عدد من الدول ايضا من جنسيات مختلفه
يقومون مجهوداتها كبيره جدا لاجلاء
رعاياهم من السودان في ظل ايضا مخاوف
كبيره جدا من قبل المواطنين الذين
يتساءلون ما هو مصير ايضا المواطن
السوداني بعد انتهاء يعني
الدول التي كانت يعني
السودان الاجنبيه نعم التي يعني
رعاياها الان غادروا اراضي السوداء فاطمه
يعني السؤال ايضا كذلك عن طيران الجيش
وسلاح الجيش السوداني القوات القوات
المسلحه يحلق في ام درمان منذ ايام ان كان
هناك من استهدافات فما هي
الاهداف التي يركز عليها الجيش السوداني
في ام درمان تحديدا
نعم يركز تحديدا على المعسكرات يعني هناك
عدد من معسكرات الدعم السريع في شمال ام
درمان وغرب وندرمان ايضا في منطقه صالحه
ايضا اليوم جرمان فيها عدد من معسكرات
الدعم السريع يعني كل هذه الطائرات اعتقد
يعني يعني تتوجه صوب المعسكرات الدعم
السريع تحديدا خاصه انه قوات من الدعم
السريع ايضا يستخدمون يعني المواطنين
دروعا بشريه فيتواجدون ايضا في الشوارع
الفرعيه داخل الاحياف فبالتالي هناك صعوبه
كبيره جدا تواجه الجيش تحديدا في عمليه
التمشيط لقوات الدعم السريع خاصه داخل
الاحياء
شكرا جزيلا لك من ام درمان
السودانيه انضمت الينا الصحفيه فاطمه
ابراهيم
ممثل ومفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين في السودان اكسيل ان نحو اربعين
الف لاجئ اضطروا للفرار من الخرطوم منذ
بدء الازمه بحثا عن الاماني في مخيمات
اللاجئين بولايات للابيض والقضاريف وكسله
واضاف بشوب خلال مؤتمر صحفي في جنيف ان
المفوضيه اضطرت لوقف معظم انشطتها الحيويه
مؤقته في الخرطوم ودرفور وشمال كردوفان
بعدما اصبح العمل في تلك المناطق خطيره
للغايه ورجح ممثل المفوضيه ان يؤدي تعليق
بعض البرامج الانسانيه الى تفاقم المخاطر
التي يواجهها الاشخاص الذين يعتمدون على
المساعدات الانسانيه من اجل البقاء وحذر
المتحدث من ان الوضع الانساني في دارفور
لا يزال في غايه الخطوره معبرا عن مخاوف
من ان تؤدي الاعمال القتاليه لمزيد من
موجات النزوح
بينما تستمر عمليات النزوح لالاف
السودانيين على الحدود المصريه قرر
سودانيون اخرون العوده لبلادهم معبر اركين
الحدودي بين مصر والسودان شاهد رحلات
العوده والمغادره التفاصيل في تقرير
الزميل احمد عثمان
في هذه البوابه من خلفه يستمر تدفق الاف
السودانيين الذين ياتون بشكل يومي هربا من
احداث الحرب في السودان الى الحدود
المصريه وعلى بعد امتار وعلى الجانب الاخر
من البوابه هناك العشرات من السودانيين
الذين ينتظرون للمرور من الحدود المصريه
وصولا الى السودان
القادمون يتوجهون الى الحافلات وعلى
وجوههم ملامح الارهاق الممزوجه بالطمانينه
فقد وصلوا الى مصر بعد رحله معاناه طويله
تاركين خلفهم مشاهد القتل والدمار واصوات
الرصاص والقذائف بيتفاجئوا بسودانيين
اخرين يستعدون للعوده لما كانوا فيه ناس
كتيره راجع لانه حصل تفلت امني في بيوتهم
فلوسنا في بيوت يعني ذهبنا احنا طلعنا
بحياتها لكن في حاجات كثيره موجوده هناك
في ناس يعني حصلت عمرهم مش ممكن يخلوها في
كثير
يعني مش ممكن
في اماكن فيها الوضع اوكي وفي اماكن الوضع
فيها يعني الخرطوم وبحري الاماكن اللي
احنا فيها للغايه الحافلات التي تستعد
للتوجه الى اسوان والقاهره تقف بموازاه
حافلات اخرى تستعد للتوجه الى بورس
السودان والخرطوم وداخلها يجلس مواطنون
يشعرون بالتعب من الانتظار لايام للعوده
ولكنهم يشعرون ايضا بالفرح بالرجوع الى
ديارهم واسرهم في السودان تحت مرمى
النيران يعني حيكون الهروب
مع بلدنا الحياه اللي عايزين نعملها نعم
لها ما نطلع برا لانه الهروب ده
ناتج الاولاد في السودان
كلكم تعلم الاحداث الجاريه في السودان في
الوقت الراهن يعني نزوح وما ادراك
فنحن
لاولادنا يعني
يومين في المعبر نسبه التقدس الكبير
للناص الجعيم من اتجاه السودان الخاشنه
لمصر الاجراءات والمواقع الخاصه بعمليات
الجوازات
والتاشيرات قد تكون كانت غير جاهزه بالشكل
المطلوب وما بين بوابتي الوصول والمغادره
يتشارك الجميع في امل انتهاء كابوس
الاشتباكات الدمويه وعوده الهدوء
والاستقرار للسودان لتبقى ذكريات هذه
الايام وما خلفته من قتلى وجرحى مرتبطه
بمعبر ارجيل الذي بات يشتهر بكونه محطه
التقاء لسودانيين الطروا للانت طويلا
للعبور الى ما اختاروه من مصير احمد عثمان
العربيه من امام معبر ارجين على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه
بدا المغرب رحله جويه لاجلاء الجاليه
المغربيه في السودان بعد ان حصل على
موافقه من طرفي الازمه لهبوط طائرات مدنيه
في مطار بورتسودان
اجراء قرابه ثلاثمائه من الجاليه المغربيه
المقيمه في السودان عبر رحلتين للطيران
المغربي انطلاقا من مطار بورت سودان فيما
عشرات اخرون من المغاربه جاري النقلهم من
الخرطوم برا الى بورتسودان الى المغرب عبر
رحلات جويه
اليوم الاول كان صعب بزاف لان الصراحه
الضرب كان حدانا ولكن الحمد لله من بعد
مشينا للبلاصه امنه
لنا كيفاش نوصلوا
الاسبوع الاول من الحرف الخرطوم كانت
اجواء مرعبه جدا كان يعني اطلاق الرصاص
داوي انفجارات قويه طائرات يعني كانت
الاجواء شويه صعبه جدا بموجب قانون الاسره
في المغرب تمنح الام المغربيه الجنسيه
المغربيه لابنها من زوج غير مغربي ما سهل
اجلاء ابناء المغربيات المتزوجات من
سودانيين الى جانب عمال ومستثمرين مغاربه
في السودان
لحظه صعبه عمر حنا اصلا عمرنا ما عشناها
الله يحفظ لنا بلادنا والله يخلي لنا
سيدنا الصراحه كانت اسوء شيء اللي عديت
انا في حياتي كامله كانت شي حاجه اللي
خايبه بزاف كتسمعنك الصواريخ وتسمع شي طلق
الرصاص حداك تقول شويه وتموت
الطريق صعيبه مقداش عندهم وكانت مسافه
ديال 26 ساعه تشير تقديرات الى ان حوالي
الفي مغربي ومغربيه يعيشون في السودان
اكثر من نصف المغربيات متزوجات من
سودانيين في انتظار ما سيصير المصالح
الدبلوماسيه المغربيه في السودان من طلبات
الاجلاء من المغاربه غير المسجلين سابقا
في سفاره الرباط هن نسوه مغربيات عدنا الى
المغرب عبر جسر الاجلاء الجوي احضرنا نصف
قلوبهن اي اطفالهن فيما تركنا نصف القلب
الثاني ازواجهم السودانيين في العاصمه
الخرطوم عادل الزبيري العربيه من مطار
محمد الخامس من مدينه الدار البيضاء
المغربيه
[موسيقى]
الان الى موجه لاهم واخر الانباء الدوليه
حيث افاد مسؤولون اوكرانيون بان روسيا
اطلقت اكثر من عشرين صاروخ كروز وطائرتين
بدون طيار على العاصمه كييف واجزاء اخرى
من اوكرانيا حيث اسفر الهجوم الروسي عن
مقتل خمسه اشخاص على الاقل وضرب مبنى سكني
في وسط اوكرانيا
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
فان كيف اصبحت جاهزه لشن هجوم مضاد على
القوات الروسيه وانها شارفت على نهايتها
واضاف وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان هناك
عوامل تهيئ هذه الاستعدادات العسكريه
للهجوم المضاد منها عوامل الطقس وحيثيه
القرار من قبل القاده للبدء والشروع
بالعمليه العسكريه المضاده
اعتبر مجلس اوروبا في قرار اعتمدته جمعيته
البرلمانيه ان نقل روسيا اطفالا اوكرانيين
بالقوه الى اراضيها يرقى الى مستوى اباده
جماعيه ودع المجلس الى اعاده الاطفال
بامان الى اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان هذه
العمليات مخطط لها بوضوح وتنظم بشكل منهجي
كسياسه دوله بهدف القضاء على اي رابط مع
هويتهم الاوكرانيه
وزير الدفاع الروسي سيركي شويغو الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها باستفزاز بعض الدول في
مقدمتها روسيا والصين لجرها الى مواجهه
عسكريه مع دول معارضه واضاف شويغو ان
الحقيقيه من هذه السياسه التي تتبعها
واشنطن هو الحاق هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا
والتشكيل تهديد للصين للحفاظ على مكانتها
الاحتكاكريه في العالم
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه عن عزمها
نشر منظومات دفاع جوي مزوده بصواريخ سام
ارض جو في بولندا وذلك بقمه
تفوق اثنين مليار دولار ياتي ذلك في اطار
برنامج تطوير نظام الدفاع الجوي البولندي
بصواريخ سام وقاذفات تكفي لتسليح اثنتين
وعشرين بطاريه الدفاع كما تعتبر الاتفاقيه
من اكبر صفقات الدفاع الجوي الاوروبي
الثنائيه في النيتو بحسب البيان الصادر عن
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
قال غفر السواحل الفلبينيه انه دخل في
مواجهه خطيره مع سفن صينيه قامت بمناورات
في بحر الصين الجنوبي حيث اشار الى ان
السفينه صينيه اجرت مناورات خطيره على بعد
45 مترا تقريبا من سفينه فلبينيه وان
السفينتين اخرى نفذتا تكتيكات عدائيه شكلت
تهديدا على سلامه سفينه الفلبينيه وطاقمهم
من جانبها الصين اتهمت الفلبين وقالت
بانها قامت بعمل استفزازي متعمد وحاولت
التسبب في حادث في بحر الصين الجنوبي
قالت وكاله عمليات التجاره البحريه
البريطانيه انها تلقت تقارير تفيد بتعرض
سفينه لهجوم الى الجنوب من بلده نشطون
الساحليه اليمني الوكاله ذكرت في بيان ان
اعيره ناريه اطلقت على السفينه البريطانيه
كما اشرت ايضا الى وجود ثلاثه قوارب على
متن كل منها ثلاثه او اربعه اشخاص
مجلس الامن بزياره الاخيره التي اجراها
الوفد السعودي والعماني الى صنعاء واثناء
على دعم السعوديه وسلطنه عمان المستمر
لجهود الوساطه التي تبذلها الامم المتحده
واعتبر المجلس ان مثل هذه المحادثات تمثل
خطوات قيمه نحو وقف شامل لاطلاق النار
ومحادثات سياسيه يمنيه يمنيه شامله تحت
رعايه المبعوث الاممي الى اليمن وذلك بناء
على المرجعيات المتفق عليها وقرارات مجلس
الامن
في ليبيا اكد مصدر محلي بان افراد الكتيبه
52 مشاه بقياده محمود بن رجب اطلقوا النار
على المحتجين والاهالي الرافدين لتمركز
افراد الكتيبه في المنطقه لتامين المدينه
حيث اشار الى ان عدد من سيارات التابعه
للكتيبه قامت بعمليات سحل بعض المحتجين
اثناء انسحاب السيارات العسكريه التابعه
للكتيبه
ادانا مجلس الامن الدولي بالاجماع حضر
اداره طالبان عمل الموظفات الافغانيات
التي يعملن لصالح الامم المتحده في
افغانستان ودعا المجلس قاده طالبان الى
التراجع بسرعه عن حمله قمع حقوق النساء
والفتيات حيث ياتي التصويت قبل ايام من
الاجتماع الدولي المقرر عقده في الدوحه في
الاول والثاني من مايو ايار بشان
افغانستان اذ سيجتمع الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو خلف الابواب المغلقه مع
المبعوثين او مع المبعوثين الخاصين
المعنيين بافغانستان من مختلف البلدان
للعمل على نهج موحد للتعامل مع طالبان
قالت وسائل اعلام امريكيه بان نائب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق مايك بينس ادلى بشهادته
امام القضاء في اطار تحقيق فيدراليا حول
دوري ترامب في الهجوم على الكبد حيث وقف
بنس امام هيئه محلفين كبرى في واشنطن
والتي تنظر فيما اذا كانت ستقاضي الرئيس
السابق ومستشاري في محاوله السادس من
يناير 2021 لمنع جو بايدن بالقوه من ان
يصبح رئيسا
شكرا لكم المتابعه تغطيه مستمره ولكن بعد
قليل مع زميل ابراهيم بدر على راس السعيده
ابراهيم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات